scp-096 versus scp-272  can the old iron nail finally be the  thing that nails down scp-096  the sinister mass murdering shy guy the  nail has the ability to pin a person's  shadow to the ground potentially leaving  them stuck there forever if the shadow  is altered by changing light it can lead  to horrific bodily contortions and  attempting to attack the nail also leads  to a horrific death because 096 only  attacks people that see its face it  would never attack the nail itself it's  also unlikely that it would be killed by  a shadow bashing due to its incredibly  durable nature however the truly  compelling question is also one we don't  have the answer to if 272 was pinning  096's shadow to the ground and someone  saw its face would it be pinned in place  let us know what you think in the  comments